Fabiano welcome to the show
congratulations uh very labored victory
for you take us through the game yeah it
was a bit of a
of a messy game and I didn't like my
position for a large part of it but yeah
he was a very long time I actually
thought that my main chance in this game
might be because he tends to get into
very serious high pressure
and you started off quite uh quickly in
the opening building up a very nice time
Advantage at this point after Knight to
H4 he thought for a very long time for
this move Rook to E8 yeah it's probably
a fun move I
I was a bit surprised by it I thought he
would play either F6 or G6 but rookie 8
he's preparing someday to get an out of
fate
and as I I thought there's a queen D6
move he played is was very annoying
because he's trying to trade Bishops
but you knew this mode no not this one
but later the later point I mean this is
this line he's played with white so I
wasn't too surprised that he played it
with black
because he wants to play either Bishop
D4 Bishop A3 and then Queen G4 he plays
Queen E6 back and I couldn't
I mean I really need to stop the bishop
trade but it's very difficult so I was
trying to find a square for my queen and
finally I found this very strange C1
Square
at first I just didn't want to go there
but then I forced myself to make it
because I didn't see how else like if
Queen D2
Bishop B4
and my queen has to move somewhere it's
every square is 83 ie3 A3 probably yeah
and you might have well yeah maybe but
also like he has Bishop C5 again he has
Bishop A3
I don't see where my queen goes if Queen
E2 then Bishop A3
and once we trade vicious my queen side
becomes very weak and also my queen on
E2 is not great because my knight
really needs to go back to that square
so yeah Queen C1 was artificial but I
wasn't sure what else to do
then I I think he played well I think it
was actually the best move by the engine
yeah maybe just to keep the game going
yeah so I think this F5 plan he played
was was good it was interesting
uh of course I'm not better but anyway
the position remains tense yeah A3 was
probably a difficult decision but I
thought it's a very good move because if
you play C5 first
then I play this Knight C3 a b95 queen
d8 ab3 I get the a file and my knight
goes to a very nice e3c4 circuit and I
thought I have a very pleasant position
okay maybe it's illegal but but
definitely I'm I'm more comfortable
absolutely and then yeah at some point I
was getting much worse I was on instead
of King hate King AJ like really was a
real relief for me
were you thinking about uh
being worse at this point and maybe uh
not being happy with the fact that you
took unnecessary risks at all no I
thought my positions worse but he has no
time so I wasn't sure if my position is
worse with that in mind uh I I still
thought I was still ambitious in this
position so you're trying to play a
practical game at this point yeah I mean
he had like seconds and it's a very
complex position and he has a lot of
weaknesses so
what can I do I have to put my Rook on
E1 and yeah yeah I was thinking first
Knight F3
but then I was scared take take and F4 I
started a bit scared I was thinking if I
could run like King to B1 that would be
very nice but it's difficult to get
there Queen H5 yeah otherwise it might
work out and King G2 he plays like uh
like Queen H5 or something
yeah that's because Queen two so yeah uh
Rook H6 first and the point is of Queen
E2 and F3 wins
and Rook H2 yeah so so yeah that's why I
took on D4 first
uh I didn't like it because his
structure his Bishop becomes suddenly
good
uh while here it's kind of limited and
after Bishop D4 cd4's Bishop is very
good yeah but okay I mean he still has a
weak King so rookie seven I definitely
misplayed it with this uh C3 move
uh sorry at the wrong moment
um and then yeah take Queen D5 I was
very unhappy King G1 and I thought B5 is
like so unpleasant because he stops
Queen C4 stuff and it was yeah that was
uh the main move by the computer I
didn't know what I was going to do here
I was thinking maybe Knight G but the
bishop can come to c5e I might even win
the a pawn but my king is under a strong
attack and if you go on H2 maybe you
have time to go F4 yeah it gets
complicated but for sure he's better so
once you played King like he had another
chance here B5 but he allowed my knight
to E3 I was suddenly not worried anymore
after 93.
uh and then here I was already thinking
I might play for an advantage
and yeah after the time control I
thought he has a really difficult
position
uh okay his moves were natural Queen D4
I thought is
and then he found this brilliant
resource you know it's uh
like I had already kind of calculated
this from far away and I thought okay
wait rookie five rookie five
and rookie five yeah
yeah why didn't I do this
that was you know I haven't heard a
question I thought he had like Queen C1
here on the king G2 F3 but I just have
Rook rookie one you pre-faced it well
though you said that he found this
Brilliance wait but Quincy one is on
okay one Rook D1 uh and Queenie Queen
[ __ ] G8 and I have Queen G4
26 King h8 Quincy yeah
yeah I probably should have exerted
myself more here I was still trying to
Blitz him and I thought Queen C7 was
winning this queen C3 was amazing yep I
mean it's his only chance yeah it's I
just missed it I thought I'm winning
after Queen C7 and the point is Queen F7
uh looks winning at the store but yeah
take take King F1 Queen H3 King E2
Queen G2 King D3 well Queen E3 King E3
Queen G3 is a repetition because I can't
go to D2 so I have to go forward King
Rook d8 King C4 Queen C2 King B4
Queen D2
I was trying to calculate uh King A3
here I thought that at the very least
he has Rook uh A8 like I just calculated
one draw for him and that was that was
not 4K for Queen D6 and if B4 there's a
funny mate here Queen D3 and if I play
Queen B3
take King takes teenage sex so
um so yeah I saw that he has a draw here
and uh and then I was just forced to go
for The Rook ending which is very
unpleasant but yeah felt very drawish as
well where did you feel he made the last
mistake
oh yeah those Rook F2 is tricky yeah
Rook C was probably Incorrect and here
well okay it's clear the last mistake is
where it takes up four yes he can play
rookie eight here I was gonna play like
Rook A4 take
uh Rook A3
take take I mean very good winning
chances but whether it's winning or not
I don't know
what taking I don't know what he was
thinking I mean my plans are are
connected they can't be taken they just
run forward
I think he probably panicked in time
travel definitely panicking time travel
he was playing on increment for the last
30 moves or so Fabiano this is a big
victory for you with the white pieces to
start successfully uh the campaign for
another championship how do you feel
your chances are looking at
right no I mean it's a decent start but
it's still so early it's such a long
tournament and 10 more games it's like a
full tournament ahead so I can't really
say much but yeah this is a pleasant
pleasant win to have an important one
for sure guys any questions our
congratulations Fabby uh keep up the
good work we enjoyed the game immensely
yes and I was wondering also are we
going to see new new chapters of in
podcasts during the tournament are you
going to do something new or you will be
focusing on there was one yesterday guys
uh yes for sure you have this guy in the
studio all day and you're asking me
yes but Christian said that your
motivation that you have to play well
not only for yourself now but also for a
podcast so do you feel this extra
pressure on your shoulders no I I don't
I tend to separate uh playing chess and
and other activities so this this
tournament would be important for me
regardless of uh whether or not we were
making a podcast
all right uh quickly fappy just because
you're in studio turning your attention
to the game between Lanier and Rey you
probably realize that they're in this
Bishop's evap is a color Berlin ending
for quite some time just your knee-jerk
reaction draw or win for white but it uh
has to be a drawn up it has to be a draw
just simple and White's only idea is I
guess uh E6 and in F6 and yeah because
if you play E6 takes F6 then E5
uh I guess he's trying to go to
to uh C5 I don't know but there will be
Bishop attacking the pawn
that's that point at some point like
yeah you just scored it he could just
put his King on C6 and then once like
let's say
let's say he waits Bishop A2 kingy
I mean again King E3 allows yeah Bishop
D6 Bishop B3
King E3 Bishop A2
King D4 just King C6
let's say Bishop C5 you just wait and uh
White's only idea is E6
take F6 but then E5 take Bishop F7
and we have a fortress
King D7 King I mean the usual but I
thought he would have very good winning
chances before I mean once he got F4 and
it looked like extremely unpleasant
but Rey is a ray is an excellent
Defender
I mean much earlier with the two Rooks
on the board I thought ah should be
serious seriously unpleasant for black
this position but
but uh maybe it's it's nothing
um all right thank you very much for
that Fabi as uh we're round three is
drawing to a close with